bachelor NIT busted there's blood tests  to make sure that everybody's clean ET  and Thurs all there's psychological  background profile angers background  checks could somebody slip through the  cracks  we're not the feds as for those pricey  bachelor and bachelorette rings how many  carats if a couple breaks up we are so  over the ring debt return the Elaine  gives these rings but I think we own the  Rings after a certain point we not  meaning me as for wardrobe contestants  and bring their own we dress everybody  and make everybody look perfect that's  not who you are but it's different if  you're the lead we take care of the  batch of The Bachelorette I can't  complain about that  Rachel Lindsay here's looking at you